let me jump back to the
idea of automated reasoning
so
the acquisition of new knowledge
has been done in this very interesting
way
but primarily by humans
doing this um yes you can think of
monks in their cells in medieval europe
um you know carefully illuminating
manuscripts and so on but it's a very
difficult and amazing process actually
because it allows you to truly ask the
question about
the
in the white space what is assumed i
think this exercise
is um
like very few people do this right they
just
do it subconsciously they perform this
by definition right because because
those pieces of elided of omitted
information of those missing steps as it
were um are pieces of common sense if
you actually included all of them
it would it would almost be offensive or
confusing to the readers like why are
they telling me all these of course i
know that you know all these things um
and so um
so it's one of these things which almost
by its very nature
has has almost never been explicitly
written down anywhere
because
by the time you're old enough to talk to
other people and so on
you know if you survived to that age
presumably you already got pieces of
common sense like um you know if
something causes you pain whenever you
do it probably not a good idea to keep
doing it
uh so
what ideas do you have given how
difficult this step is what ideas are
there for how to do it automatically
without
using humans or at least not
you know doing like a large percentage
of the work for humans and then humans
only do the
very high level supervisory work
so we have um
in fact
two directions we're pushing on very
very heavily currently at sitecore and
one involves natural language
understanding and the ability to read
what people have explicitly written down
and and to to pull knowledge in that way
but the other is
to build a series of
knowledge editing tools knowledge entry
tools knowledge um
capture tools knowledge
testing tools and so on think of them as
like user interface
suite of software tools if you want
something that will help people to more
or less automatically expand and extend
the system
in areas where for instance they want to
build some app have it do some
application or something
like that so i'll give you an example of
one
which is something called
abduction so you've probably heard of
like deduction
and
induction and so on but abduction is
unlike this abduction is not
sound
it's just useful so uh for instance um
deductively if someone is out in the
rain and they're going to get all wet
and
when they enter room they might be all
wet and so on
so that's deduction
but if someone were to walk into the
room right now and they were dripping
wet
we would immediately look outside to say
oh did it start to rain or something
like that now
why did we say maybe it started to rain
that's not a sound logical inference but
it's certainly a reasonable
um
abductive
leap to say well one of the most common
ways that a person would have gotten
dripping wet is if they had gotten
caught out in the rain or something like
that um so um
what what does that have to do with what
we were talking about so suppose you're
building uh one of these applications
and the system gets some answer wrong
and you say oh yeah the answer to this
question is
this one not the one you came up with
then what the system can do is it can
use everything it already knows about
common sense general knowledge the
domain you've already been telling it
about
and context like we talked about and so
on and say well here are
seven alternatives each of which i
believe is plausible given everything i
already know and if any of these seven
things were true
i would have come up with the answer you
just gave me instead of the wrong answer
i came up with is one of these seven
things true and then you the expert will
look at those
on seven things and say oh yeah number
five is actually true and so without
actually having to tinker down at the
level of logical assertions and so on um
you'll be able to educate
the system in the same way that you
would help educate another person who
you were trying to apprentice or
something like that so that that
significantly reduces the mental effort
or significantly increases the
efficiency of the teacher the human
teacher exactly and it makes more or
less anyone able to to be a teacher um
in that um in that way so that's that's
part of the the answer and then the
other is that uh the system on its own
will be able to
um through reading through
conversations with other people and so
on
learn the same way that
you or i or other humans do
you